[MUSIC]
It's 102 degrees,
a pretty normal Dubai summer evening.
My brother and I, we see the gold and
navy Chevy Tahoe parked around the corner.
Even though we had just finished
soccer practice, we make a dash for
the AC we know is waiting for us.
As we get closer,
we see our mom in the driver's seat and
our two cousins in the car waiting for us.
We haven't seen them in a couple years,
so as soon as we hop in,
there are those enthusiastic hellos
that you know teenagers are famous for.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Hey, what's up?
>> Not much.
Cool.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So our mom asks,
how was soccer practice?
Good, but I'm really tired.
Yeah, I know,
I have no idea how Cameron is so fit.
I notice our cousins
giving us weird looks.
Yeah, seriously he is the most
fit guy on the team, and
I'd been training all summer.
Weird, right?
Well, my cousins are British, and
if you know anything about their lingo,
my brother and I had just been describing
how attractive our teammate Cameron was.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The same words mean different things
to different people, and
it doesn't stop there.
You'd hear all sorts of interesting things
at an international high school in Dubai.
For example,
talks about who had the highest quality
phone would get weird looks
from our Korean classmates.
To them, quality meant brand new.
Or why my Japanese classmates
would start laughing.
To them, quality meant zero defect.
The same words mean different
things to different people.
But let's be real, calling your teammate
hot by accident, or describing your
Nokia 3310 as a zero-defect phone,
>> [LAUGH]
>> Is kind of funny.
Well, sometimes the different
meanings of words aren't so funny.
Sometimes they lead to
distance between friends,
distance in our communities,
distance in our society.
And surprisingly,
one of these words is dialogue.
So some of you are looking at me the same
way my cousins did that day, and
I can't blame you.
For many in this room,
the following definition of dialogue
found in an essay titled the Power
of Dialogue, will resonate.
It's defined as a discussion aimed
at fostering mutual insights and
common purpose.
Sounds like a great definition, right?
Well, there's an increasing body of
research done by experts, like Jacob Hess,
that focus on the negative connotations
conservatives hold of this word.
It's actually pretty interesting,
many people are concerned with the luck
of conservative representation.
By some estimates, 90% of those involved
with the concept either through funding
it, developing it, or
advocating for it, or liberal.
So why do I care?
Well, these types of conversation have
been a fabric of my family growing up.
I had four grandparents
that were all teachers,
both my parents have lived
all around the world.
I have two younger brothers,
we're 15 months apart, and
I really hate to admit this right not,
but not only are they taller than me,
they're also smarter.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The youngest is getting his PhD
in geoscience.
And the middle one made
the smartest decision of us all,
he decided not to go to grad school.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All of this is to say we don't have
the stereotypical relationship
with conversations about values,
or the world, or politics.
For us, it's exciting and expected for
us to bring our different perspectives
to the dinning room table or
during the holidays.
So with that kind of upbringing,
you can imagine how excited
I was to come to the GSB and
have these types of conversations with
some of the smartest people I've ever met.
That all changed about a year
ago when President Trump
announced his immigration ban.
I was really excited to understand what
my classmates thought of the issue, so
I decided to form some
small discussion groups.
Well, fast forward to couple of
weeks to Wednesday, February 22,
I'm in Arbuckle Dining Hall talking with
one of my more conservative friends,
let's call him Jim.
We're talking about current events,
and eventually,
we start talking about the ban.
Wow, Jim, I bet a lot of our classmates
would love to hear that perspective,
you should join one of the groups I'm
putting together in a couple weeks.
Sure, sounds good.
Who's going to be there,
what are the details?
I list a couple of people.
All right, so what's the format,
how is it going to be structured?
It's going to be pretty casual,
during the evening, over pizza.
It's just going to be
a dialogue on the issue.
He grows silent, I'd said something wrong.
I don't think that's for me, sorry.
Really, why?
I don't know if I want to sit there and
be lectured on my views on the issue.
No, no, no, no, this is going to
be a dialogue, where we try and
understand each other.
Yeah, I know what dialogue is,
I'll pass, thanks.
I probably shouldn't
have been that surprised.
Earlier that week, I'd sent an email to
another conservative friend with a title,
finding the right forum for dialogue.
He responded with, really appreciate
the efforts to open up discussions, but
don't believe this is the right place for
me to help, sorry.
So why was my message so off?
Even though it's not required, many expect
dialogue to alter their views on issues.
If you are in a room and
you are participating, usually,
it's to mediate conflict.
And to do that it's usually required that
you find common ground, or you're looking
for solutions, or consensus, which
all require you to change your views.
So if the overwhelming majority of
organizers of dialogue are liberals,
most of the time they're looking for
common ground, and
many times it's expected that participants
will soften or change their views.
Hopefully now you start to see why
conservatives view this as a tool liberals
use to bring people to their side.
So what did I decide to do about it?
I decided to dive into the research and
understand why this term was
alienating some of my friends.
I had lunch with Keith Hennessey,
a former advisor to George W Bush.
I took a class with James Fishkin,
the Director for
the Center of Deliberative Democracy.
I had multiple calls with interfaith
dialogue expert Randy Paul.
If the same words mean different
things to different people,
research has shown that reframing
the concept of dialog can
reinforce the healthy norms of discourse
that are practiced on both sides.
So armed with this view of the issue,
I was able to successfully host
multiple discussion groups last quarter
with not just those two friends, but
with several of our
conservative classmates.
I did so partly by highlighting the
following three benefits of dialogue, and
as you try to engage with others
in similar types of interactions,
I hope you can remember
to mention them as well.
Expand your knowledge.
Even if you believe you possess the
objective truth, participating in these
types of conversations allows
you to test out your beliefs.
And gain new and
interesting perspectives and
information you otherwise
would not have perceived.
Advocate effectively,
those that participate in dialogue
are better missionaries and advocates.
If the world doesn't see an issue
in the way you would like, or
in the right way, participating in this
discussion will help you understand why.
Own your story, dialogue is an excellent
platform for people to become their own
platform, and not just defined by others
or organizations, like mainstream media.
The problem is as we shy away from
these types of conversations,
we have false assumptions
that certain groups speak for
an entire movement, or that false
assumptions continue to persist.
So for example,
ISIS does not represent all of Islam, and
neither does one conservative
movement represent the entire camp.
This, though, is lost when we aren't
the ones talking about our own personal
stories in these types of conversations.
So different meanings of words
can lead to some funny stories.
And sometimes it can lead to distance.
Or other times,
they're the foundation of a country.
We hold these truths to be self-evident,
that all men are created equal,
that they are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights.
The phrase all men are created equal
means something different to us
today than it meant to
our Founding Fathers.
And that's okay, they had different ideas,
different assumptions,
different connotations, but
they worked through it.
They did so by defining those
differences and the benefits of them.
Today, let's do the same thing.
Let's realize that dialogue can mean
different things to different people.
But better yet, let's reframe
the concept in a more inclusive way, so
we all want to participate.
Doing so
will literally make us a better country.
And by the way, is it just me, or
is the world literally starting
to mean something different these days?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]